بدأت علي بابا يوم الفردي
بحفل مدته أربع ساعات يضم
أعمال السيرك والمشاهير ، وانتهى
اليوم بمبيعات تقارب 31 مليار دولار ،
وهي أموال أكثر مما
ينفقه الأمريكيون في يوم الاثنين الإلكتروني والجمعة السوداء
مجتمعين.
احتفل بكونك عازبًا
دائمًا في 11 نوفمبر
، لذا بدأت في الصين في التسعينيات ،
اختطفت علي بابا العطلة من أجل
تخفيضات المبيعات وبعد عشر سنوات
أصبحت منجمًا للتسوق ،
وعادة ما تختبر الشركة نماذج أعمال جديدة
خلال  لم يكن هذا الحدث وهذا
العام مختلفًا مثل Amazon Alibaba لديه
بعض متاجر البقالة التقليدية
التي دفعوا مبيعاتها ليوم واحد هناك
ويجب أن يكون لدى المتسوقين حساب IPE بالكامل
للدفع في تلك المتاجر ، لذا
تحاول Alibaba حقًا جذب هذا المتسوق عبر الإنترنت إلى
من المحتمل أيضًا أن تلتقط المتاجر غير المتصلة بالإنترنت عددًا
قليلاً من المستخدمين الآخرين الذين سيتسوقون مع
Alibaba على مدار السنة ليس فقط في
أيام العزاب ، ومثل جميع عمالقة التكنولوجيا الكبيرة ، فإن Alibaba
لديها أيضًا الكرة الأرضية  كانت طموحات هذا العام
هي المرة الأولى التي يدفعون فيها
مبيعات يوم العزاب في جنوب شرق آسيا من خلال
منصة تجارة إلكترونية يمتلكونها تسمى
lozada الآن ، بينما حققت Alibaba مبيعات
في الداخل والخارج ، وكان هناك تباطؤ كبير
في النمو هذا العام الذي بلغ
30 مليارًا.  كانت الدولارات ضخمة بلا شك ،
لكن النمو في المبيعات كان
أقل بكثير من العام الماضي في عام 2017 ،
نمت مبيعات يوم العزاب بنسبة 40٪
إجمالي هذا العام فقط 27٪
من الأشياء التي أدت إلى تراجع
الاقتصاد الصيني المتباطئ ، وزيادة المنافسة من
شركات التكنولوجيا الأخرى بالإضافة إلى
الحرب التجارية الجارية بين الولايات المتحدة والصين ، لكن
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في علي بابا قللوا من شأن
الرياح المعاكسة الجيوسياسية قائلين إن الشركة
ستستمر في الاستفادة من
علاقات نائب الرئيس التنفيذي للطبقة المتوسطة المتنامية في الصين ،
قائلا إن هذا الاتجاه لن يوقف
التجارة أكثر أو لا يوقف التجارة أكثر.